hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about one of the most controversial
subjects that people are talking about
in Game of Thrones right now that is the
coming together of Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen as a couple or if you prefer
the shipping of Jon and Daenerys to use
the parlance of our times
yeah generis this will contains spoilers
for everything in Game of Thrones
through season 7 episode 4 so you have
been warned
during episode 4 and even more so after
and re watching the episode for the
other videos I made about it it became
abundantly clear that John is Daenerys
I'm moving into heavy relations in a
hurry after meeting in episode 2 for the
first time this isn't a new idea by any
means this is something that's been
speculated on since these two characters
existed basically once we realize that
they're both very important it becomes a
possibility that they will come together
and there's a lot of other hints and
things that come up in the books and the
show that lead us in that direction too
for what it's worth this isn't something
that bothers me personally but I'll
explain more about that later for now
let's look at 10 reasons why they
probably are getting together and why if
you're against it you're probably going
to have to get used to the idea then
we'll talk about some of the main
arguments against and at the end I'll
add my two cents into the whole
situation
the first reason on the list of why
John's and Eric's are probably going to
get together is because in episodes 4
inside the episode which is where Dan
and Dave talk about some of the parts of
the story that they flushed out David
Benioff says they're attracted to each
other now if anybody knows what's going
on with characters in this show it's the
showrunners they have creative influence
on everything so I'm going to take this
as an indication that that part of the
story that Jon and Daenerys are
following for each other
the second thing that points towards
this happening is that when they release
the new photos this week we get another
shot of them together and it's just
inescapable to see that they are
building up this tension having feelings
for each other
the third reason that they're probably
getting together it's because they are
literally ice and fire now the books are
called A Song of Ice and Fire so you can
easily get to the idea that one is ice
and one is fire and the main argument
that most people have for this is that
well-drawn is ice and fire so he doesn't
need a nurse but I think it's a little
bit more than that and I'm not someone
who's always subscribed to this idea I'm
just saying that what the evidence we
have now this seems to have a little bit
more influence and the thing is is that
dawn does have the blood of the Dragon
and stark blood but John also went up
north of the wall and died and then was
resurrected so there's sort of a longer
connection to ice and the average person
there right he went and he saw the army
of the Dead so on and so forth Daenerys
on the other hand walked into the fire
she went into Drago's funeral pyre and
came back out so yeah that's just not
who their families are there's literal
connections to Ice and Fire for both of
them that one leads to the next one
which is they're both more or less
perceived as gods for coming back from
those situations like Daenerys is called
the unburnt when John came back after
Melisandre brought him back she was
convinced that he was Azure Ahai reborn
also her torment tell John that the
wildling
think of him as a god and frankly if he
told more people about his resurrection
they probably would too came back from
the dead in the show also there's some
similarities in the way they presented
these scenes and others such as those
iconic scenes or we see John at the
battle as a bastard surrounded by all
the people and we had that one of
Daenerys where she was being held out by
the freed slaves this one also leads
into the next one and that is they're
both super good candidates for the
prince that was promised ORS or hi I'm
not saying either one of them is or that
they both are any of that kind of stuff
I'm just saying that there has to where
they are right now are so similar in
that we can make a good argument for
either one of them fulfilling those
prophecies also if you think about it
MELAS
Kandra was wrong at first she won for
Stannis but at this moment he's
convinced that John is a Zora hi and
last season we saw that Kim Baro was
pretty damn certain that Daenerys was
the one that was promised as the way
that she said it by the same prophecy
the fifth indication that they're
probably going to get together is that
they both lost their first love in
pretty tragic ways of course we know the
story of regret and Khal Drogo so I
won't retell them but suffice it to say
that they both loved and lost and
neither has had another character that's
come in to take that first lovers place
the sick hint that they're probably
going to get together is that vision of
the house of undying that Daenerys has
this is different in the book in the
show but in both there's indications
that point towards John in her vision in
the books she sees a blue rose on the
wall which we don't see in the TV show
but we do see her at the wall so if we
look at that as the interpretation of
what the book was showing it pretty much
points to John being important in her
story the seventh reason that they're
probably going to make a nice couple
sometime soon is that people follow them
in the last episode we heard miss Andi
explained that to Davos and John and you
pretty well know that if things were the
other way around and Daenerys had gone
north and she asked Lyanna Mormont why
she follows John the story would be
pretty similar now they both had
problems in that area John being killed
by the colors of the night watch stands
out and yeah but in general there seems
to be a leadership quality that people
are drawn to in both of them which means
that if they were a team or a duo or in
the context of this video a couple that
would probably be amplified the eighth
reason why John Daenerys will probably
end up together is one that's not very
sexy really but it's just sort of a
matter of fact that there's no one else
for either of them like at the end of
last season as Daenerys is leaving
Daario behind she points out that
marriage is a great way to build up the
power and who else is in the running and
Johnson the exact same both all of the
characters that gave all the female
characters they sort of brought out in
the north Lyanna Mormont and Alice
Karstark are basically kids so there
really isn't characters that they're
developing outside of the two of them ix
reasoning goes back to the first reason
and it is the reason why I had decided
to make this video this week everything
we saw in the last episode just points
to it they certainly had feelings for
each other that were coming out when
they were in the cave it's probably not
a coincidence that they're in a cave
since John and regret kind of took
things to the next level at the cave
when Davos asked him about looking at
her like he's seen her looking at her
good heart John doesn't deny it he tried
to switch things and he tries to act
like it's not the most important thing
that's going on which I said in my last
video is absolutely saying that yeah I
like her why wouldn't you like her the
evidence is just there whether you like
the idea or not everything that we've
seen since they've met is pointing in
that direction and the tenth and final
reason that it's probably going to
happen is it just makes sense I know a
lot of people myself included at times
have just not wanted this to happen
because it makes so much sense but John
has seen the army of the Dead he
rightfully is most concerned about
staking humanity from these people
Daenerys is absolutely the only person
that's in possession of a magic that
rivals the magic they're up against in
the north
she has dragons dragons are very good at
burning things so even though he's going
to take all that dragonglass back with
him the real weapon that will be
effective in this war are those dragons
so if you put all of the other nine
things together and add in the fact that
he can't bend the knee or he won't bend
the knee there's only a few different
ways we get from point A which is them
not deciding to put together to point B
which is to work together and battle
this very real threat that's coming
or one of those is a marriage and the
other one of those is if they have a
child or if she becomes pregnant and
that ties them together without a formal
marriage and then there's a bunch of
other ones that don't really go along
with what we're talking about here so
I'll ignore them for now so those are
the reasons that it's probably going to
happen and there's only really two main
reasons that people don't want it to
happen the first is the one that's most
absurd to me because well no they're
both pretty absurd but I guess I
understand why the second one freaks
people out more than the first one the
main reason that a lot of people don't
like it is they think it's cliche I
think it's too predictable low-hanging
fruit for telling a story whatever you
want to say people don't like it because
that's what you would expect to happen
now I was just having a conversation on
Twitter the other day that finally made
this make sense to me because my
thinking has always been the writing in
these books is so good I can't imagine
that if this is George RR Martin's plan
that it won't be enjoyable and I'm not
saying he can't make a mistake and
things can't go wrong but he hasn't led
us down yet
so I brought that up in relation to the
idea that why would people say that it's
too predictable and that's a deal
breaker because that's sort of like
saying we don't trust the author to be
able to write a good story if that's the
case and the response that I got was
that yeah that's sort of true but some
people have real emotional attachments
to these characters and yeah and now
that makes a little bit of sense see
these have not ever really been my
favorite character I like them both I
thinking when reading I got more into
John's story towards the end and started
to grow a little bit more tired of
Daenerys but they're both awesome
stories and the thing with these books
are in this world in general is there's
so many good characters mine just
happened to be different people so yeah
I get it some people might not really
like this idea because they had
something else in mind and I see this
all the time with twin peaks' which you
know that has the same kind of people
have been liking some of these
characters as their favorite characters
for 25 years and to see them not be how
they thought that we're going to be is
really hard and you know my thinking is
the same way there it's like well this
is you know we trust that this guy is
going to tell us
a story so yeah that really kind of
opened my eyes to that so if you're
really against this that's why I'm
saying you're going to have to probably
get used to it because everything is
pointing in that direction at this time
and then the other reason that people
don't like the idea is because that
their blood related and I could go on
and on about this but basically this is
not a factor in anything in this
relationship targaryen four generations
have married brother to sister so an
aunt mary and nephew is not a big deal
plus there's no influence of like a
religion or religious organization here
and you know that's where most of that
kind of stuff comes from in our world
but even there I mean it's people have
been marrying their relatives with the
blessing of the church for a long time
especially powerful people but that's
not what this video is about just keep
that in mind that doesn't matter at all
to anybody they aren't aware that
they're related anyways and they're
probably going to find out this season I
would imagine if not definitely by next
season should they might find out next
episode I don't know but when they do it
won't change anything as well as their
prospects of being together it won't
change the fact that they might get
married it won't change the fact that
they might have children it's just not a
deal-breaker in this story so yeah like
you know like I said I don't really have
strong feelings about these two getting
together but I have noticed that people
do it's really kind of fascinating how
strong some people's feelings are
against Daenerys I mean one of the
things that makes this world great these
stories great is that grayness of the
characters like nobodies all the way
good nobody's all the way bad the good
guy doesn't always win all that kind of
stuff but it's really kind of
fascinating man people are ready to jump
on Daenerys for anything in this world
that is exactly that way like I can't
think of other characters who somehow
like on a higher plane of existence but
yeah man people get feelings people
definitely get feelings so tell me in
the comments what yours are do you think
it's going to happen are you going to
freak out if it does happen
stop watching if it happens please like
this video if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel and set
notifications because I've been putting
out a lot of videos and you won't want
to miss one follow me on Twitter
and thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon